[Música]
con esta primera invitada del día vamos
a hablar de Corea del Norte que disparó
hoy jueves otros dos misiles balísticos
de corto alcance al mar de Japón se
trata del sexto lanzamiento en 12 días
el misil de Rango intermedio sobre el
nuevo territorio nipón aumentando la
atención en la Península salemos a María
Pío devoto coordinadora de la red de
seguridad humana para América Latina y
el Caribe Gracias María Pía por estar
con nosotros esta mañana jueves en
directo América de Francia 24 hablemos
de estos lanzamientos que se han
incrementado y que han lanzado estos
últimos días en Corea del Norte Por qué
lo hace en un momento como este no
qué tal Buenos días un saludo a toda la
audiencia Bueno hay algunos analistas
que sostienen que es por ambición hay
otros que dicen que forma parte una
retórica anti japonesa hay otros que
dicen que es una señal para Estados
Unidos Porque con este alcance podría
llegar a la isla de guama en realidad es
una combinación de todas estas cosas
pero es una demostración de poder en
este momento hay una atención en otro
lado las armas nucleares están
nuevamente en el centro de la escena con
Rusia con sus amenazas veladas sino tan
veladas la respuesta a Estados Unidos
entonces Esto hace que países y líderes
como Kim Jong quieran convertirse su
país en un estado nuclear por las
tensiones regionales que hay desde el
2006 que está haciendo ensayos nucleares
Corea del Norte pero nunca nunca con
misiles
balísticos con este gran alcance
Entonces esto pone en estado alerta a
Juan
en Japón y a Corea del Sur puede que
esto genere que haya algunas voces en
Corea del Sur y en Japón que quieran
estar y que estén evaluando contar con
armas nucleares no pero Esto hace que
porque no se sienten seguros de la
protección que tienen por parte de
Estados Unidos casualmente el ex
ministro japonés asesinado recientemente
era de esta línea dura María Pía es
porque no se defienden de alguna manera
o tienen una retórica más fuerte los
países en la Península por lo que estaba
comentando de que temain no tener un
respaldo completo de Estados Unidos
digamos a la hora de un conflicto mayor
Estados Unidos ha reafirmado su Alianza
con Corea del Sur y con Japón es más
está haciendo ensayos y militares con
ejercicios con Corea del Sur con Estados
Unidos y ahora con la intervención de
Japón Esto hace que Corea del Norte se
sienta amenazado por una posible
invasión pero sí salió
inmediatamente el presidente de Estados
Unidos porque es la primera vez que hay
un ensayo de este tipo durante la
presidencia de biden a reafirmar su
Alianza con Japón y su apoyo a Corea del
Sur pero ahí siempre hay voces
disidentes quién está apoyando ahora a
Corea del Norte China podría estar
también detrás apoyando a norcoreano a
los norcoreanos aquí
bueno en el se vio claramente en el
debate del Consejo de Seguridad del día
de ayer que no se pudieron tomar
acciones concretas para
tratar el tema de estos ensayos de Corea
del Norte del Norte no con Rusia y China
acusando a Estados Unidos de ser el
provocador de estos ensayos y a Estados
Unidos acusando a
Rusia y a China de instigar y de apoyar
a Kim son un y de alentarlo a tener
estos desarrollos
María Pía también le quería preguntar
como un país tan pobre como Corea del
Norte con tantas necesidades una crisis
alimentaria una crisis de salud en fin
puede tener armas nucleares no y
enfocarse digamos en este Arsenal
armamentístico
Bueno hay una relación entre el programa
de armamentos de Corea del Norte y la
economía norcoreana O sea a mayor
expansión del programa armamentos mayor
caída de la economía o sea este año
puede sufrir una gran contracción puede
estar cerca de una hambruna como de los
años 90 el programa de alimentos de
Naciones Unidas dice que el 40% de la
población está en estado de desnutrición
y más allá de las malas gestiones y de
los fracasos de los distintos programas
de la economía esto comenzó con las
sanciones impuestas Desde los primeros
ensayos pero Corea del Norte tiene una
una una proporción exagerada del
producto bruto interno en gasto militar
es el más alto del mundo es un 25%,
cuanto los países están entre el 1 y el
4% hay algunos que tienen
mayor proporción de gasto militar como
puede ser el caso de Arabia Saudita como
el caso de Libia pero siempre muy lejos
de el caso de Corea del Norte que
estamos hablando de un 25% o sea y en
realidad para resumir en este contexto
geopolítico actual con el espacio que
están ocupando nuevamente las armas
nucleares que han dejado de ser un tabúl
la utilización por parte de Rusia de la
de la disuasión de la disuasión nuclear
es un caldo de cultivo para estas
ambiciones desmesuradas Y estos orgullos
nacionales como es el caso de Kim Jong
uno o sea sabemos lo que pasó y lo que
lo que va a seguir pasando en el Consejo
de Seguridad y si se diera una carrera
armamentística estaríamos viviendo en un
mundo muchísimo muchísimo más frágil la
única solución es La abolición de las
armas nucleares la adicción al Tratado
de prohibición de armas nucleares del
2017 Pero esto implicaría una decisión
política muy fuerte por parte de los
estados nucleares no estamos hablando de
Corea del Norte sino aquellos estados
nucleares que tienen este el derecho de
posesión de armas nucleares por el
tratado de no proliferación con este
gasto tan fuerte armamentístico María
Pía pues me sale una duda no el sobre
todo el secretario estado de Estados
Unidos blinken dijo que sí Corea del
Norte sigue por este camino pues
aumentarán las sanciones y también todo
el aislamiento que tiene este país
debido a las sanciones actuales también
y un país tan empobrecido de Dónde sacan
los recursos Cómo cómo se financia no
para poder tener este gasto
armamentístico bueno por un lado tenemos
proporción del producto bruto interno de
por otro lado ha encontrado la manera de
evadir algunas de las sanciones para
poder exportar antes exportaba cobre y
ahora exporta pelucas o pestañas
postizas digamos y China ha jugado un
rol muy fuerte en Corea del Norte
ayudándolo a eludir estas sanciones a
través del contrabando O sea hay una hay
una gran Alianza entre Corea del Norte y